Let's talk about some of
the great innovations that
are happening at local
levels in our workplaces
across the country.
If you're like me,
I'm sure you're
frustrated with
the gridlock that
is blocking any progress in
public policy in Washington.
I've seen this go on for
30 years in our field
where Congress and the
President can't pass anything
because there's an impasse
between business and labor
on employment and labor policy.
So we need to look to other
places for innovations today.
The good news is that
there's a lot going on
at the local level in
established companies,
in startups, in state and local
governments, in non-profits.
And so that's
where historically,
most of our major innovations
at work have occurred.
So let's look at a few of these.
You've heard of companies such
as Southwest Airlines started,
in 1970.
It's the most profitable
airline in the United States.
It has consistently been rated
as one of the best places
to work.
It has great customer
satisfaction,
and it has low prices.
And it's worked effectively
for shareholders
and for employees and for
customers for many years.
So that's one example,
but there are others.
Across almost every
industry we can
find good companies
that are able to provide
good jobs at high
profits and good service
to their customers.
In the health care
area you often
hear about Kaiser Permanente,
a major nonprofit health care
provider that both is an insurer
and clinics and doctors offices
and has hospitals.
Google, as you all know, is
one of the greatest employers
today.
It's got the resources to
have parties on Fridays
and treat employees well
and encourage them to work
creatively on their own work.
Here in New England,
we celebrate the work
of Market Basket, one
of our grocery chains
where employees went on
strike to support their CEO
to save the business culture
and the business that
was good for employees
and good for customers
and good for shareholders.
We'll talk more about Market
Basket in future sessions
of this class.
On the West Coast, there's
a similar organization
called In-N-Out Burgers, again
a retail restaurant which
is doing very very well.
So there are
companies that do this
but then there are new
forms of work emerging out
of the so-called
on demand economy
with names like
Uber, TaskRabbit.
Companies that disrupt
traditional ways of organizing
work and that bring
customers more directly
into the work process.
We will discuss the
pros and the cons
of these new ways of working
throughout this course.
And we see equally
exciting innovations
all across the world.
The Swedish furniture
maker Ikea, for example,
is a global leader in
environmental sustainability,
in serving low income
customers with good quality
furniture at reasonable prices,
and providing good working
conditions, including ensuring
that its lowest paid employees
earn a living wage.
Or consider Semco, an
innovative company in Brazil
that has gained a reputation
for empowering employees
to control their own jobs
and their work schedules
and yet has grown to
become Brazil's most
successful company.
The CEO who grew and shaped
the company, Ricardo Semler,
was recognized by the
World Economic Forum
as one of the global
leaders of tomorrow.
But what about innovations
on the labor market side?
Well, in the 20th
century, unions
were the source of
tremendous innovation.
They're happy to tell you
that they are the group that
brought you the weekend.
And, in fact, that's true.
They negotiated for
time off for holidays,
for weekends, for various kinds
of vacation pay and sick leave
pay.
But unions, as you can see
here, have fallen on hard times.
They have lost membership
going from about a third
of the workforce down to
less than 15% percent today,
and in the private sector,
they're even lower at about 7%.
But in the wake of
this decline, we're
seeing new forms of worker
organization emerge.
Sometimes they're
called cooperatives,
sometimes they're
called worker centers.
Sometimes they're called
fast food strikes,
as we've seen against
McDonald's and other industries.
Sometimes it's protests
against Walmart
on Black Friday where
workers are protesting
low wages in that industry.
But we're seeing
these organizations
come along and develop their
own form of innovation that
helps to represent workers
and provide workers
a voice that allows them to
improve their own conditions
on the job.
And some are using social media
to provide new opportunities.
You've heard about
Mechanical Turk, which
provides jobs for people who
can sign up on the internet
to do coding jobs and other
very basic kinds of things
that they can do from home.
Well, this thing called
Turkopticon has come along
and it said, we
will rate employers.
Are they good employers?
Can we trust them?
Do they pay their
employees wages on time?
Do they live up
to their promise?
This is all done
spontaneously to organize.
So we're seeing new
forms of organization
like this come along.
So we can do this.
We need to continue
to put our good faith
efforts into creating
innovations at the workplace.
We need to ask then, how can
we take those innovations
and spread them
across the economy
so that more and more people can
benefit from these good ideas?
That's our job.
I look forward to
seeing more innovations
and I look forward to seeing
what you and your generation
creates as the
next form of work,
the next kind of
organizations that
will meet the needs
of our economy
and our society going forward.